what you say if someone says that they
have to talk to their business partner
they have to talk to their husband or
they have to talk to their wife before
they make a decision the first thing you
do you say well what would happen if
they said no if they say i would do it
anyways then boom you close the sale if
they say well i don't think i would do
it if they said no then you ask why do
you think they'd be opposed to this now
obviously they haven't even talked to
their spouse yet but they're going to
give you the real reasons that they're
actually against it and then you can
confront those and then if they still
don't want to say yes after confronting
those decisions you then rely on past
agreements what that means is you say
well do they know that you're struggling
with this problem yes are they happy
that you're struggling with the problem
do they approve of the current condition
you're in that you're struggling they
say no then why would they be opposed to
you fixing something they already don't
approve of as you rely on the past to
get them to say yes and at the very end
you say hey at the end of the day
sometimes it's better to ask for
forgiveness than permission right right
and you close the deal